body crushing pressure toxic atmospheres
unbearable temperatures that's what
would be in store for you if you visited
other planets in our solar system but
what other environmental hazards would
you encounter
planets would be the safest and which
would be the most dangerous
and how long could you survive on any of
them
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you spent a day on every
planet in our solar system
before you get started on your journey
through the solar system you should pack
a bottle of water Earth is the only
planet known to have consistent bodies
of liquid water on its surface so if you
pack enough you probably survive a few
days just about anywhere right
well sorry to say I've got some bad news
for you
let's start with a visit to Mercury the
smallest planet in the solar system this
Rocky crater filled planet is only
slightly larger than our moon and it's
located extremely close to the Sun at a
distance of 58 million kilometers
now even though a day on Mercury equals
about 59 days on Earth your trip
wouldn't last anywhere near that long
due to this slow rotation you could land
on the sunny half where the temperatures
reach
430 degrees Celsius or maybe you'd aim
for the dark side where temperatures
drop to minus 180 degrees Celsius
your best bet would be to find a cozy
Spot somewhere in between but with an
atmosphere mainly composed of oxygen
sodium hydrogen helium and potassium
good luck breathing for very long even
in this Middle Ground you wouldn't
likely survive more than two minutes
okay let's check out what a day would be
like on the second planet from the sun
Venus
well you should expect a very warm
welcome because surface temperatures are
of piping hot
475 degrees Celsius
and one day on Venus lasts
243 Earth days
unless you've got an impossibly robust
spacecraft you couldn't get very close
to the surface
and even if you did you wouldn't last
very long Venus has a thick and toxic
atmosphere with 154
000 times more carbon than the
atmosphere of Earth and it's shrouded in
yellowish clouds of sulfuric acid
say the venusian atmosphere is a runaway
greenhouse effect
between the toxicity and the heat
burning you to a crisp you wouldn't
survive one second on Venus
now let's skip on over to Mars
unless you wanted to stop back on Earth
for a couple breaths of fresh air
on Mars you'd find comfort in a day that
is a little over 24 hours
what you wouldn't find comfortable is an
atmosphere of carbon dioxide argon
nitrogen and a little bit of oxygen and
water vapor
surface of Mars is cold with an average
temperature of minus 62 degrees Celsius
combine the low surface temperatures
with the unbreathable air and you
wouldn't survive much more than a few
minutes here either
first planet you wouldn't be able to
reach the surface
that's because there isn't one on the
gas giant Jupiter this planet is more
than twice as massive as all the other
planets in our solar system combined
and its atmosphere is primarily hydrogen
helium and cold windy clouds of ammonia
and water
Jupiter might be bulky but it rotates
fast
one day lasts a mere 10 Earth hours and
because it's so fast Jupiter's
atmosphere has strong jet streams plus
the Great Red Spot that is actually a
storm bigger than the size of Earth if
you fell into the planet you would enter
the atmosphere at a whopping 49
kilometers per second and as you kept
falling the atmosphere would become
denser and more turbulent you might feel
like you were slamming into a wall again
and again
if you made it
692 kilometers down you would find
pressure levels higher than at the
bottom of the Mariana Trench the deepest
place on Earth if the pressure didn't
kill you the temperature which averages
minus 145 degrees Celsius certainly
would
you wouldn't survive on Jupiter for one
second
now if you continued on to Saturn you'd
find another gacious giant without a
surface and like Jupiter a day lasts
about 10.7 hours
here
experience deadly strong winds reaching
up to 1800 kilometers per hour
with an unbreathable atmosphere made of
hydrogen and helium Saturn is incapable
of supporting life maybe you'd have more
luck on one of its moons
like Titan or Enceladus these two moons
have internal oceans which could
theoretically support life
okay moving on to the first of the ice
giants in our solar system Uranus
[Music]
no surprise here that it also has an
unbreathable atmosphere of hydrogen
helium and methane which gives the
planet its signature blue-green color
and the stink of rotten eggs
there are some other unusual hazards on
Uranus you'd need to be prepared for
such as mysterious flares of X-rays and
lethal Diamond rain
yeah you heard that right highly
compressed diamonds of carbon atoms
raining down from the atmosphere
but don't worry about that the immense
pressure on this planet would kill you
in less than a second
all right last but not least Neptune
a dark cold planet with supersonic winds
as strong as 2 000 kilometers per hour
that's faster than the top speed of a
fighter jet so if the pressure didn't
kill you those supersonic winds would
probably do the trick a day on Neptune
would last for 16 Earth hours but your
life there wouldn't last a second
okay there it is so in case it isn't
clear Earth would be the only planet you
would want to visit anytime soon
just about anywhere else you could look
forward to a deadly cocktail of high
pressure and toxic gas
imagine never being able to dream of
landing on mars or traveling to Saturn
not because it's impossible to get there
but
because they didn't exist
because Earth was the only planet in our
solar system
what would the night sky look like
where would the Earth be located
and how would Humanity evolve
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth was the only planet in
the solar system
the other eight planets in our solar
system aren't just pretty to look at or
something that we strive to travel to
one day
even though they're billions of
kilometers away they've played an
essential role in life here on Earth
so what would happen if they never
existed
each planet in the solar system played a
vital role in the development of Earth
billions of years ago and they continue
playing a vital role in keeping earth
safe today
for example take the placement of every
single planet they all have their own
little space in the galaxy and that's
not by accident
our planets work together to keep each
other in place
for example if Mercury and Venus cease
to exist Earth might drift closer to the
Sun and if Jupiter or Saturn disappeared
instead of getting closer to the Sun the
Earth might drift further away from it
this would cause a number of issues for
us Earthlings
right now we're lucky enough to live in
what scientists call the Goldilocks zone
they call it that because Earth sits in
the range of orbits around the Sun that
are just right to sustain life
if Earth were to move closer to the Sun
it would get a little bit hot
we might burn to a crisp
the farther away we get the more the
temperature would drop
Earth would be too cold to sustain life
the position of Earth in our solar
system not only affects life but
everything that happens on our planet
it affects our Seasons the length of our
days and how long our year is but
unfortunately the time we wake up will
be the least of our worries
with Earth being the only planet in our
solar system there's no telling where it
might end up
we could be all the way in the back
where Uranus and Neptune used to be
or somewhere right up front
where Mercury once was
it's safe to say that no matter where we
end up if it's not the Goldilocks zone
there's a pretty good chance there
wouldn't be any life here on Earth
if life did form somehow it would
definitely be aquatic
that's because without any other planets
keeping us in check Earth's gravity
would be severely different
when we say no other planets we mean no
moons either
the moon's gravitational pull is
responsible for the tides here on Earth
without it our Waters would remain still
the oceans wouldn't rise or fall they
would just stay where they were so
really Earth as we know it wouldn't
exist if there were no other planets
there's virtually no chance that
Humanity would be living today but what
if instead of the planets never existing
in the first place one day they suddenly
disappeared
well apart from Earth violently moving
around not knowing where to go we'd also
have another huge issue to worry about
asteroids
it's clear that every planet is critical
to life on Earth
if just one planet suddenly disappeared
a number of issues would go along with
it
there are two planets that have a very
special role in keeping earth safe
Jupiter and Saturn
that's because while Earth is hanging
out thriving with life
Jupiter and Saturn are getting beat up
by millions of asteroids
flying through our solar system there
are hundreds of millions of asteroids
that are trying to kill Earth
luckily we hardly see any of these and
that's thanks to Jupiter and Saturn
because of their enormous size and
gravity they do an excellent job of
pulling asteroids into them so that they
never make it to Earth
with these planets gone Earth would be
bombarded by asteroids not good in case
you've forgotten a single asteroid hit
Earth millions of years ago wiping out
the entire dinosaur population
so this would end up being pretty bad
Earth would soon be covered with massive
craters and once again life would cease
to exist
luckily you won't have to worry about
any of this
you can rest easy knowing that Earth
sits comfortably in this perfect little
spot in the universe where we can all
live and thrive
[Music]
make room Earthling we're moving the
other planets in our solar system into
our planetary neck of the woods
would all the planets fit into this
Goldilocks zone
what kinds of gravitational chaos would
this cause
and does this mean life would exist on
the other planets
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all the planets of the solar
system were in the habitable zone
liquid water is a key ingredient for
life and in our solar system earth is
the only planet with liquid water on its
surface
that's because our planet is located in
the habitable zone of our sun also known
as the Goldilocks zone and the
conditions here are you
are just right
any closer and water would boil away any
further it would freeze
the size of this area depends on how hot
or cool a star is
scientists have discovered 4 000
exoplanets within habitable zones but
only 24 of them might be able to support
life
in our solar system this zone is within
a range of 0.9 to 1.2 astronomical units
from the Sun
so if we parked all the other planets
within this 45 million kilometer patch
of real estate could we kick start
extraterrestrial life
with eight planets to squeeze in the
Goldilocks zone you need to get creative
the last thing you'd want to do would be
disrupt the conditions for life on Earth
right well to start this scenario off
you'd need to move Mercury to the
innermost portion of the habitable zone
at around 0.9 astronomical units that
would be more than twice as far away
from the Sun as Mercury orbits now
not much would change on this rocky
planet except for a refreshing coolness
after billions of years of scorching hot
temperatures
Venus already orbits relatively close to
the habitable zone at 0.72 astronomical
units when our son was a young star and
dimmer Venus was essentially located in
a habitable zone it could even have had
conditions for life with a shallow ocean
of its own
but as the sun got hotter that
Goldilocks zone was pushed further back
temperatures increased and the oceans
boiled away
maybe relocating Venus to a cooler spot
away from the Sun could make it
habitable once again
now it would be time to do some
calculating you've got five more planets
to squeeze in it could a good idea to
make sure all the planets are an equal
distance apart with our narrow
Goldilocks zone you could place each
planet six and a half million kilometers
from each other
that would be equal to about 30 times
the distance between the Earth and the
Moon
moving us away from our current location
would make this whole experiment a
little less chaotic but at about 0.97
astronomical units
things would get warmer here
bad news for the climate crisis
uh ignoring that for now you'd move on
to Mars
excited to see if this cold rocky planet
could have life
well sorry to say it would still be
barren
you see liquid water isn't the only
thing that life needs to thrive Mars
lacks a magnetic field
that means solar radiation would strip
away the chances of it having an
atmosphere you'd still have to terraform
it
you'd likely not see any life popping up
on the remaining geishas planets either
the gas giants Jupiter and Saturn have
atmospheric pressures and temperatures
far too intense for molecules like DNA
to be stable
but you could probably take a cold dip
on one of Jupiter's moons Europa its new
proximity to the sun would allow its
thick ice layer to melt
feeling refreshed you'd realize that the
last planet in our solar system Neptune
is now even closer to us than Mars is
today
that means in our new solar system
Arrangement Planet hopping would be a
reasonable Adventure
even with current technology you could
travel between the planets in 90 days
and Beyond the exploration there are all
kinds of resources you could extract
from the other planets
you could get hydrogen fuel from Jupiter
and Saturn to help us transition to a
low carbon future you could mine Cobalt
from asteroids this would be important
to developing Renewable Energy Systems
but this new solar system would be a
little unstable to say the least
especially with a massive Planet like
Jupiter so close to us it has two and a
half times the mass of all the other
planets in our solar system combined
scientific reports indicate a star
similar to our sun could have six
earth-sized planets within its habitable
zone
with Jupiter gravitational stability
would be all out of whack and all these
imbalances could result in the planets
or moons getting ejected from orbit or
reshuffled completely
[Music]
billions of years from now the sun will
become a red giant and then it will
slowly die
that's right it's the it's the end of
the solar system and this is your
Survival Guide
what will happen when Earth becomes too
toasty to sustain life
where else in the solar system could
human civilization live
and what would the sun be like in its
final days
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you survived the end of the
solar system
for around four and a half billion years
our sun has been the bright center of
our solar system it's fueled by the
nuclear fusion in its core and it burns
through
661 million tons of hydrogen every
second
during its Stellar lifespan the sun has
burned through about half of its fuel
source
that means our son has another 5 billion
years left in it
as the sun uses up its hydrogen through
nuclear fusion it becomes more saturated
with helium and that makes it spit out
even more energy
every billion years that it burns
hydrogen our sun gets about 10 percent
brighter eventually all that energy will
push out the sun's outer layers and our
star will swell in size
then we'll have a red giant at the
center of our solar system
game over right
let's fast forward to around one and a
half billion years from now sorry to say
but things won't be looking too good for
life on Earth
the sun's increased brightness will set
off intense global warming our planet
will become so hot that our oceans will
start to boil
the increasing heat and radiation of our
sun will shift the habitable zone of our
solar system and now the area where
liquid water could exist will move out
toward Mars
yeah Mars will now become habitable and
it could be Humanity's first destination
for settlement but to create a
breathable atmosphere we'd still have to
terraform the red planet
at this point Mars could remain
habitable for as long as 5 billion years
that'll give us plenty of time to make
our next move but in about seven and a
half billion years our solar system will
have a giant problem a red giant problem
of course
our star will run out of its hydrogen
fuel and start burning helium instead
the sun will expand completely
vaporizing Mercury
the atmosphere of Venus will burn up
eventually the expanding sun will
swallow Venus whole
and our Earth
well it will get reduced to a dense hot
iron core our new home on Mars won't be
habitable anymore either
Humanity's best hope would be to hop
over to Europa Jupiter's fourth largest
moon
its thick layer of ice will melt from
the sun's increased heat
Europa could become a wonderful Water
World
Jupiter's moon could be our home for a
few hundred million years that's when
the sun will reach its maximum size as a
red giant it will shine about 3 000
times brighter than it does today
and its surface could extend well beyond
Earth's orbit
8 billion years from now the sun could
make life intolerable as far as Pluto
our best hope at that point would be to
find a home on a distant dwarf planet in
the Kuiper belt the temperatures there
could be similar to what we were used to
on Earth
life on Earth would be a thing of the
very very distant past for this
generation of humans
two billion years after that our Sun's
fuel reserves will completely dry up
sun will become unstable and will start
to pulse
this will cause it to shrug off its
outermost layers
the sun will change from a red giant to
a white dwarf this means it will shrink
until it becomes the size of Earth today
it will blast off massive amounts of
X-ray radiation but less heat so the
habitable zone will dramatically shift
once again it could go from the Kuiper
belt to about where mercury used to be
for human civilization to continue we'd
have to move onto another star's
habitable exoplanet
our white dwarf star would radiate for
quadrillions of years so moving back to
its new habitable zone wouldn't be a
good idea
when our former son used up the last of
its energy it will no longer be able to
shine or radiate heat
but it will still have mass and
gravitational pull
it may become a black dwarf
scientists have yet to find any such
stars as they would have to be much
older than our 14 billion year old
universe
when I say jump you say how high okay
let's put this to the ultimate test by
hopping around the solar system
literally
what differences in gravity would you
experience
on which planet could you jump as high
as a house
and on which planets would jumping lead
to your demise
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you jumped on every planet in
the solar system
every object with mass is subject to
gravity
this includes you of course whether
you're standing on your two feet or
lounging on the sofa the Earth's gravity
is pulling you toward the center of the
planet
when you jump the force of your muscles
allows you to overcome that gravity and
accelerate upward
once you're in the air gravity slows you
down and eventually your velocity hits
zero and you fall back to the surface
the planets in our solar system come in
all sizes so the force of their gravity
differs too
your mass would stay exactly the same
but from one planet to the next your
weight would be very different
so could you bound gracefully over
mountains on one while on another you'd
barely be able to lift a toe
your interplanetary jumping experiment
would begin right here on Earth okay not
the most exciting place to start but a
good place of comparison
if you're close to the average jumper
you should be able to squat swing your
arms and leap about half a meter high
all in about one second
but don't let me underestimate you
if you're an extremely talented athlete
like Javier Sotomayor you could set a
new world record by jumping over
2.45 meters whoa not too shabby
making a quick first stop on the moon
you'd find gravity six times weaker than
it is on Earth well that's because the
moon has about 80 times less Mass
here you'd only need to jump at a
velocity of two kilometers per second to
lift off the surface and with your
average jumping velocity you should be
able to jump about three meters high
meanwhile Earth's most talented jumper
would be able to bound over an entire
house
okay moving on to the rocky surface of
the planet closest to the Sun Mercury
with a spectacular close-up view and
temperatures hitting 430 degrees you'd
be drenched in sweat already
Mercury is smaller than Earth the
gravitational pull is about one third of
what you're accustomed to here at home
so despite exhausting conditions you'd
be able to jump about three times as
high okay let's get out of the frying
pan and Into the Fire by taking a leap
on an even hotter planet Venus
very similar in size to Earth this
planet has a surface gravity about 91
percent of Earth's
here you'd be able to jump ever so
slightly higher than you could back home
but you definitely wouldn't want to hang
out for too long in this thick scorching
hot atmosphere
so time to cool off on Mars
you better keep your leg muscles warm
though the average temperature on the
red planet is minus 62 degrees
but the good news you'd feel lighter
Mars has about 10 times less mass than
Earth and for this reason you'd be able
to jump to nearly the exact same height
as you did back on Mercury
okay now leaving the rocky planets
behind it would be time to test your
skills on a gas giant like Jupiter this
planet is so large that all the other
planets of the solar system could fit
inside it Jupiter has very intense
gravity so you'd be feeling a lot
heavier than you do right now
if you tried to jump here you'd only be
able to get a pathetic 20 centimeters
off the ground
now if it helps your ego this scenario
would be impossible for a simple reason
it's because the gas giants have no
surface to jump from so you'd have to
say on top of your spaceship and if I
can offer some advice don't fall off
on Saturn you'd be surprised to find
that you can jump only about three
centimeters less than you could on Earth
despite the planet having 95 times the
mass
Saturn's surface gravity is quite
similar to our home planet
okay now heading toward the dark cold
edges of the solar system you'd take
your leaps on Uranus and Neptune just be
sure to avoid slipping on these ice
giants on Uranus you'd find a relatively
familiar gravitational pull
because of this you'd be able to jump
about six centimeters higher than you
could on Earth
finally
surface of
net despite your aching muscles you'd
power through for one last jump
and that could be tough considering the
severe winds that dwarf even the largest
hurricanes back on Earth
but you'd take your best shot and
struggling against the slightly stronger
gravity
you'd reach 44 centimeters
roughly the same as back home
[Music]
speaking of back home I think it's time
to head back
what would happen if our planet got too
close to a black hole
well according to science fiction we'd
be sucked into a parallel universe
or maybe even the future
but in reality it wouldn't be nearly
that fun
our planet would be ripped apart piece
by piece starting with our atmosphere
so what if we moved a little further
back
instead of the black hole being right
beside us we move it to the center of
our solar system
would our planet still be destroyed
and what would that do to our solar
system as a whole
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the solar system orbited a
black hole
this black hole has the same mass as our
sun
if we were to place it next to our sun
the two objects would orbit each other
at a close distance about one-tenth the
distance between Earth and the Sun
this would mean that our solar system
was now orbiting a local point with
twice the mass of the sun
as a result the planets would have to
orbit faster to avoid getting pulled
inwards
a year on Earth would decrease from 365
days to 258 days and the amount of
energy from the Sun would vary as it
orbited closer to and farther away from
Earth
other than that life would pretty well
be the same
but what if we replaced our sun with a
black hole completely
Well we'd have a lot more to worry about
than just the length of a year which by
the way would be over in the blink of an
eye
[Music]
the biggest problem we would face if we
replace the sun with a black hole would
be the absence of incoming solar energy
the planet Earth would go completely
dark
thanks to our planet's Infamous
greenhouse gas effect the global
temperature wouldn't be reduced
instantaneously
but after the first week Earth's average
surface temperature would drop to zero
degrees and then to negative 101 degrees
by the end of the first year
you think that our planet quickly
becoming an ice world would be bad
enough but we're just getting started
without sunlight there would be no
photosynthesis the process by which all
plants generate food
small plants would die in a matter of
days
this would create a ripple effect
throughout the entire food chain causing
us all to starve to death eventually
but maybe there is a way we can get
usable energy from a black hole and it
all starts with something called CMB
CMB also known as Cosmic microwave
background is the weak radiation left
over from the Big Bang
theoretically if a black hole spins fast
enough it can compress the CMB radiation
into Optical wavelengths the same
wavelengths that are emitted by the Sun
the wavelengths would funnel into a
narrow beam and before you know it our
planet would have usable energy once
again all right
but there is a small catch
the faster rotation of the black hole
would also pull the planetary orbits in
closer to the point of no Escape
for the planetary orbits to remain
stable and avoid being sucked up the
orbital velocity of the planets would
need to be close to the speed of light
this means that a year on Earth would be
over before the blink of an eye
so much for your big New Year's Eve
party
but there's no time to worry about that
because we've got bigger issues coming
our way
if any material like meteors satellites
or space debris get sucked into the
black hole it will result in a blast of
radiation coming our way
and when the radiation arrives at our
planet it will blow away our atmosphere
killing anything in its past
so even though the sun can be annoying
sometimes
when it comes to things to orbit around
we could do a lot worse unlike Earth
which is orbiting the Sun there are
billions of rogue planets roaming the
Milky Way not bound to any host star
one of them has been spotted on the edge
of our solar system what if this
Interstellar object swung through it how
would this space invader affect the
orbits of the planets could it possibly
push Earth out of the habitable zone
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a rogue Planet entered our
solar system
if a planet doesn't belong to any star
system it's considered a rogue planet
this is an Interstellar planet with a
catchy name just 20 light years away
from us
it's nearly 17
000 times the size of Earth and has a
powerful magnetic field that makes the
planet glow with Incredible auroras
what if this massive Alien Planet
trespassed the borders of our solar
system would this mean the end of life
here on Earth
once the interstellar Planet invaded our
solar system things could go very wrong
this Rogue Planet would likely be moving
at hundreds of kilometers per second if
we were unlucky enough to be on a
collision course with this massive alien
object the Earth would be completely
demolished
but don't worry our solar system is
quite big and the chances of the Rogue
Planet bypassing us without a fatal
Collision are pretty high
instead our Interstellar guest would be
busy disturbing the orbits of all the
planets in the Solar System
that's because a rogue Planet nearly 13
times bigger than Jupiter would have a
huge gravitational impact making other
planets orbits including Earth's more
elliptical and that's when the bad news
Begins for life here on Earth
the Earth is orbiting the sun's
relatively narrow habitable zone within
this Zone also known as the Goldilocks
zone it's not too cold sore water
doesn't turn to ice and not too hot so
it doesn't get vaporized and neither do
we just perfect
change the Earth's orbit and the
conditions for Life won't be so great
the Rogue Planet may not push us out of
the habitable zone but it would bring us
much closer to the Sun for very short
and exceptionally hot summers
those extreme Summers would be followed
by long and super cold Winters
quick Summers would leave us less time
to grow crops by the end of our first
never-ending winter Humanity could face
food shortages even Extinction the Earth
might be thrown into the next ice age
instead of global warming we'd be
worried about global cooling
we'd rethink our energy sources and try
to pump out more greenhouse gases to
warm the planet up a little
solar energy on the other hand would be
considered very inefficient in the
winter time but could be used very
effectively during the short blaze of
Summer
count on things being much worse if the
Earth gets knocked out of the habitable
zone at that point the Earth would
considerably cool down
all our water would freeze and so would
we this would be the end of most life on
Earth the only way we could survive
would be if we learned to live at the
bottom of the ocean next to deep sea
thermal vents that push out extremely
hot water
maybe eventually we'd evolve into a
different life form that would take
control over the frozen planet
lucky for us the universe is enormous
there's a lot of space between rogue
planets and other objects in our galaxy
and that makes this scenario very
unlikely
moving it's never easy
the packing and unpacking
having to start fresh and make new
friends
all this can be challenging but let's
face it whether it's a nasty landlord or
imminent threat to humanity
sometimes you just have to move
in another what if we looked at moving
the Earth to avoid certain danger but
what if that wasn't enough what if we
had to build a stellar engine to move
our entire solar system
how could we do it
where would we go
and what would happen to us here on
Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we moved the solar system
to move our solar system would require
an incredible amount of energy and
careful planning
we could potentially do this with a
stellar engine
a class of hypothetical megastructures
using a star's radiation to create
usable energy
thankfully with our planets locked in
orbit of the sun due to its immense
gravitational pull
we only have to find a way to propel the
Sun and our planets and moons will
follow
Russian scientist and aeronautical
engineer Leonid scadoff proposed an
ingenious method to move our sun using a
giant parabolic mirror known as the
shkatoff Thruster it works by harnessing
the sun's photons and reflecting them
back around the sun creating thrust
each Photon carries a tiny amount of
thrust meaning if you are in space and
you turned on a flashlight you would
eventually move
just very very slowly
the sun produces 10 to the power of 45
photons per second this impressive
energy makes the Sun the most powerful
nuclear reactor ever as a result we
would have to position this parabolic
mirror exactly over the sun's poles to
avoid burning one of our nearby planets
this limits the direction we could move
and it would likely take us 230 million
years to move 100 light years
that's an astronomical amount of time so
is there a faster and more efficient way
we could move the Sun
astrophysicist Matthew e Kaplan of
Illinois State University has proposed a
new type of engine called the Kaplan
thruster
this Stellar engine requires one
quadrillion satellite mirrors known as a
Dyson swarm to orbit the radius of the
Sun
these would reflect the sun's energy in
a concentrated Area Heating it up and
shooting the Sun's mass and solar winds
outward allowing us to utilize the
billions of tons of hydrogen and helium
collected using large electromagnetic
fields
a thermonuclear reactor on board could
conceivably convert the helium and
hydrogen into radioactive oxygen used as
exhaust to propel the craft and any
leftover hydrogen from the Sun would be
shot in a jet of plasma using a particle
accelerator pushing the sun forward and
keeping the Thruster from being sucked
into the Sun's gravity
this delicate Balancing Act would allow
us to move in any direction we want at
much greater speeds
the real challenge might be building the
Dyson Sphere itself
for one thing we would have to mine
Mercury for its Rich supply of metals
and minerals
this would take a considerable amount of
time and effort but could provide us
with an almost infinite energy source
learn more about that in our other video
what if we built a Dyson Sphere
now what would it feel like on earth
when our entire solar system goes
surfing through space Well turns out
everything might feel more or less the
same
researchers at Illinois State University
believe that shifting the solar system
wouldn't disrupt our planet's orbits
since the thrust of a stellar engine
would create just a small acceleration
overall as we orbit the sun the sun
orbits the galactic center of the Milky
Way
we don't feel this movement because it's
constant if the Earth suddenly stopped
moving however we'd be in Cosmic trouble
with so many travel destinations in the
universe we'd still be limited to only a
small portion of it known as the local
group
this collection includes our massive
Milky Way galaxy the Andromeda and
triangulum galaxies and about 50 other
dwarf galaxies
now due to the mysterious force of Dark
Matter scientists have discovered that
the universe is rapidly expanding
even though we can see them all the
other Galaxy groups are moving farther
away from us at speeds we'll never be
able to reach
we'd be better off looking for other
habitable planets like ours within our
own Galaxy
in approximately four and a half billion
years our Milky Way will eventually
collide with the Andromeda galaxy
forming milk dromeda
at this point galaxies outside the local
group will be so far away we won't even
be able to detect them like we can now
future civilizations born in the milk
dromeda universe may think that the
local group is all that there is
they wouldn't be able to learn about the
big bang and may think that the universe
is static and never-ending
so consider yourself lucky to be living
in a time where we can research the past
and possible future of our own universe
maybe someday we will harness our
Stellar energy and get to explore our
galaxy and make some new friends along
the way
this would make us a type 2 civilization
on the kardashev scale
which measures a civilization's
technological ability to control and
utilize energy
sadly we're barely a type 1 civilization
as we still haven't figured out how to
harness all of Earth's available energy
with the vastness of the universe
everything in it seems so spread out
but some objects are closer than you
might realize
every now and then a random Interstellar
asteroid passes through the Oort cloud
the wall of icy debris at the very edge
of our solar system but what if a rogue
star unceremoniously rampaged right
through the Oort cloud
how bad would it be if it brought other
planets along for the ride
this is what if and here's what would
happen if another star entered our solar
system when it does
if another star rampaged through the
solar system the extent of the chaos it
would cause would depend on the size of
that star and its trajectory
when Schultz's star passed through the
Oort cloud it came five times closer
than Proxima Centauri the closest star
to our solar system
Schultz's star didn't have much effect
on Earth
although around the same time early
humans almost got wiped out by a massive
volcanic eruption
but that was pure coincidence
right
in any case before Schultz's star turned
away minding its own business
it did change the orbits of about 10
percent of comets and asteroids in the
solar system
but what if it was a bigger incoming
star like blizza 710 that's currently
making its way towards us
glisa 710 isn't scheduled to make its
first contact with the solar system for
another 1.29 million years
but when it does it could shake the
Earth quite a bit
at first the Rogue star would make its
way into the Oort cloud
at this point it wouldn't affect us
directly but it would send massive
chunks of Space Rock showering the solar
system
about 170 meteors comets and asteroids
would hit the Earth every day
if the Rogue Star had other planets and
moons following it our solar system
would turn into a galactic soup with
stars and planets being pulled out of
their orbits
massive collisions would create a
Rippling effect disrupting planetary
orbits even more
eventually the Earth would be knocked
out of its orbit too if it wasn't
already destroyed by meteor storms and
the remnants of other planets
not to sound too dramatic but there are
estimates that 40 000 stars have entered
the Oort cloud at some point in the
history of the solar system but they all
came here on just visiting trips
chances that any of those Rogue Stars
will ever make it past the Oort cloud
are close to zero
and sucking up every bit of matter in
its past
the most massive black hole in the known
universe is headed right toward Earth
what would you see as it started to
slurp up the Milky Way galaxy
what kind of tasty dish would Earth
become
and when it's finished with us
where would it go next
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the largest black hole entered
our solar system
black holes aren't that much different
from any other object in the universe
that has mass except that they are
really really dense at their Center is a
singularity an infinitely small point
where all its matter is compressed
the more matter that's condensed into
the singularity the stronger the
gravitational pull
most black holes are the remnants of
massive stars and generally range
between 10 to 100 solar masses
for the record one solar mass is the
equivalent of 333
000 Earths
that's a lot of gravity
but super massive black holes which lurk
at the centers of many galaxies could
contain millions or billions of solar
masses and scientists think that there
are black holes as large as 100 billion
solar masses
AKA stupendously large black holes or
slabs catch one of these moving toward
our solar system and get ready to wave
bye bye to all your conceptions of space
and time
the largest known black hole ton 618 has
begun its long track directly toward our
solar system with its 66 billion solar
masses in tow and long Trek is no
overstatement it would be traveling at
least 10 billion light years to reach us
as it's steamrolled through space it
would gobble every bit of dust and gas
in its path
it would also snack on many stars before
it even reaches the Milky Way
depending on its route this could mean
hundreds of billions of stars added to
its size
before making first contact with our
galaxy it would have pulled in enough
matter to disrupt its neatly organized
spiral
you'd be able to detect its initial
approach toward us as You observe the
increasingly intense radiation it emits
eventually it would come bearing down on
the last of the Milky Way's spiral arms
the Orion arm
ton 618 would gobble up its entire 20
000 light year length
it would be like an unbelievably long
Buffet line straight to the center of
our galaxy
somewhere along this line it would
finally knock on our front door
the orc cloud is a spherical shell of
icy debris that surrounds the solar
system
or at least it was before tun 618 showed
up
it would then continue on its way and
consume the Kuiper belt just beyond the
orbit of Neptune
the danger to Earth would steadily
increase as hundreds of thousands of icy
bodies would be sent hurtling this way
as ton 618 kept pushing forward
it would Devour the ice giants Neptune
and Uranus and the gas giants Saturn and
Jupiter would be pulled apart Adam by
Adam
not only the planets but their moons and
every asteroid that the giant black hole
comes across
any future plans by us to settle on Mars
would be squashed as the red planet
would end up right smack in the middle
of this black hole too
and now there would be nothing left in
the way of tons 618 and Earth
now while the center of this
stupendously large black hole would be
almost 295 billion kilometers away we'd
finally be right up against its Event
Horizon that's the boundary marking a
black holes point of no return
the pull of its gravity would now be
totally inescapable
our whole planet would stretch out while
simultaneously getting more and more
compressed
eventually Earth would become like a
strand of spaghetti slurped into an
empty black void
then this black hole monstrosity would
gobble up the sun in one big gulp and
now at the center of what was once our
solar system tons 618 would occupy
nearly as much space it would extend
almost all the way to the inner edges of
what used to be the Oort cloud
and since it's not polite to leave any
food on your plate ton 618 would
continue on its path toward the black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
Sagittarius A star as these two massive
black holes Collide the Collision would
be so powerful that it could cause
ripples in the very fabric of space-time
but hold on what happened to you as you
got pulled into the black hole
well that's a story
for another
what if
foreign
[Music]
body crushing pressure toxic atmospheres
unbearable temperatures
that's what would be in store for you if
you visited other planets in our solar
system but what other environmental
hazards would you encounter